[Music]
meat is choking our planet
if you care about climate change and you
have red meat on your plate you are not
taking this seriously nearly 15 percent
of greenhouse gas emissions come from
crop and livestock production meat is
incredibly environmentally intensive all
the land all of the water all the carbon
intensity what people put on their
plates today impacts the future of the
planet sustainability will come into my
head
but i can't really get my taste buds
around like the mushiness of corn i just
fall back onto meat
even as meat consumption around the
world increases people are being offered
more and more choices to make their
diets more sustainable but can meat
alternatives really lead to a more
sustainable world
[Music]
28 year old jay taylor has been
kickboxing for nine years
i had my first proper fight in 2014.
i'm just trying to push on from there
and progress as much as i can now
eight weeks before a fight jay enters a
strict training regime a vital part of
that is his diet protein for my diet is
fundamental
i need to make sure i'm hitting the
right amount keeping my muscle mass as
high as i can
and healing
protein helps you heal
[Music]
wow
you get me an egg out please yeah jay's
girlfriend lydia has been vegetarian for
two years okay thank you
i found at uni that i ate less meat
because of affordability and it being
better for the environment
lydia would like jay to follow suit i
like to talk to joe about phoenix just
to make him aware that
i mean everyone knows that meat isn't
the best for the environment it's the
tastiest
it's not though if you actually had an
open mind when it came to your palette
we can have dinner i look at your stuff
and i see mine and i'm like
nah stick with that
jay is not the only one in a british
survey 76 percent of people said they
cared about the environment but just 26
would stop eating meat and other animal
products to reduce their environmental
impact
two-thirds of people said they would
rather die five to ten years younger
than give up meat
and that's a problem
because we humans eat a lot of meat
wow sharon's 90th birthday she thought
it goes to rain
from the british meat marketing board to
american fast food chains the public's
been fed juicy cuts for decades
327 million tons of it globally each
year
how about a little british beef british
beef makes everyone feel at home
the idea behind the project is that
we're investigating the impact of eating
meat and dairy on the environment leap
is a four-year research project
analyzing global food systems i've
learned that eating beef has a much
bigger environmental impact than eating
chicken
the man behind it is oxford university
professor sir charles godfrey one way of
thinking about this is to do a thought
experiment let's suppose we cure the
greenhouse gas emissions from all of the
economy apart from food so we solved
heating we solve transport but we
haven't sold food if we continue
business as usual with the food system
into the future
emissions from the food system alone are
sufficient to push us almost certainly
over 1.5 and probably over 2 degrees
warming and two degrees of warming
that's about the maximum that we could
possibly have without really disruptive
climate change
so if we care about climate change we
really do have to think about the food
system the food system as a whole is
responsible for about a third of the
world's greenhouse gas emissions
almost half of that comes from crop and
livestock production
if everyone was to switch to a
plant-based diet then our greenhouse gas
emissions would go down quite
substantially
the earth is dying we are not saying
this 14 000 scientists across the world
are unequivocal evidence of climate
change as climate change gets pushed
higher and higher up the political
agenda more and more companies coming up
with alternative products that attempt
to fill the desire for meat
and here in california is one that puts
tackling climate change at the heart of
its mission
market leader impossible foods is
helping to transform a sector which was
valued at 29.4 billion dollars in 2020
but is forecast to reach 162 billion
dollars by the end of the decade
[Music]
the company was founded to really
effectively address two big global
crises the first big global crisis we're
all talking about right now it's it's
climate change the second issue that is
not necessarily getting quite as much
airtime but is very much related is the
extinction crisis
so that's just loss of biodiversity it's
loss of wildlife and that is something
that is very much linked to climate
change but is potentially even more of
an urgent issue
to help it deliver on its mission the
company asked a sustainability
consultancy to measure the overall
environmental impact of every one of
their products and compare it to the
animal equivalent
for the impossible burger it's about 89
percent less greenhouse gases it's about
87 percent less water and we need about
96 less land and you know we've found
them to actually be pretty effective in
terms of a consumer engagement tactic so
there's a lot of interest at the moment
in the environmental effects of
alternative protein now we can
say with confidence that
those type of alternative proteins which
are now operating at scale for example
producing plant-based proteins then they
tend to have a lower environmental
impact than producing meat in the
traditional way
greenhouse gases could be reduced by as
much as 70 percent if everyone was to
switch to a vegan diet
but that really does seem impossible
just five percent of americans identify
as vegetarian and only two percent is
vegan numbers that have held steady for
years
so to really make an impact on the
environment it's going to need an
alternative that's palatable to the
millions who are determined not to swap
their meat for plants
can you do the honours and lift the lid
on your creation
i can
there's quite some intense taste it's
close to meat in 2013 the first
lab-grown or cultured meat burger was
created it cost a whopping 330
000 to produce
fast forward to december 2020 a
californian firm eat just becomes the
first to get regulatory approval in
singapore for its cultured meat
so we start with a cell
and we get a cell from a biopsy a cell
bank a fresh piece of meat then we
identify nutrients to feed the cell so
think about the soy and corn that goes
in the chicken's body and then the
muscle and the fat in the body ends up
growing and then instead of having the
animal's body in a warehouse growing we
grow our meat in a large stainless steel
vessel kind of like brewing beer called
a bioreactor and the end product is what
you're used to
it's real meat it tastes like chicken
because it is chicken
producing meat and steel vessels in
warehouses dotted around towns and
cities could free up vast amounts of
land it would allow countries that
currently import most of their meat to
simply grow it themselves
and of course there could be more direct
environmental benefits too with this
approach you don't need to tear down
trees it's less carbon intensive use
less water and significantly less land
so both from a carbon a land a water
perspective orders a magnitude better
you can build facilities really anywhere
these are not facilities that require
tens of millions of acres you can make
it pretty close to home
recent studies looking at the potential
environmental benefits of cultured meat
production found the global warming
impact could be reduced by as much as 92
percent but in reality it's too soon to
tell this is an industry that's still in
its infancy
because that has yet to be taken to
scale it's very hard to estimate what
the environmental effects are going to
be at the moment they tend to be quite
high but that's because they're done
in laboratories using a lot of
electricity in principle and certainly
people in the field argue there is a
potential for it to be considerably less
with cultured meat yet to hit the mass
market and plant-based alternatives
seemingly still an acquired taste it's
clear that for now it'll take more than
consumer choice to help deliver a more
sustainable world
you've got to do what's right for the
planet and to get that change you're
going to need a persuasive alternative
currently the alternatives out there
aren't that persuasive for me
and whatever the potential benefits the
food industry as a whole is unlikely to
turn green unless it's led there
i think that sort of more relevant for
policy is that
were there to be a shift towards more
plant-based diets that would have very
positive effects for the environment but
i would say that arguments like that
very much worried livestock producers
completely understandably their
livelihoods depend on producing meat so
i think it's very important to think how
we can transition from our current diets
to diets with
less meat in it but that also is a just
transition for the people that are
involved in the system
the plant-based meat industry the food
systems
sector as a whole hasn't really had at
any level
the level of policy engagement that the
transportation sector has the energy
sector has even the built environment
sector has
if you look at the improvements that
have been made in how we source energy i
think we can attribute a lot of that to
policy interventions for the time being
though innovative businesses pushing
meat alternatives may have to settle for
saving the planet one burger at a time
thanks very much for watching you can
read more about the future of food and
my technology quarterly by clicking the
link and please don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]